el médico realizará una cistoscopia para
diagnosticar las condiciones del tracto
urinario
el sistema urinario o tracto urinario
produce orina y la excreta del cuerpo
incluye los riñones los uréteres la
vejiga y la uretra
en los hombres la glándula prostática
envuelve a la uretra en la parte
inferior de la vejiga cuando la sangre
circula atraviesa los riñones donde los
desechos y el líquido extra son
extraídos para crear la orina luego la
orina baja los uréteres para almacenarse
en la vejiga un músculo expansible con
forma esférica durante la micción la
orina sale de la vejiga a través de la
uretra y es eliminada del cuerpo
al permitir que el médico mire el
interior de la uretra la vejiga y las
aberturas de los uréteres a través de
una cistoscopia se pueden revelar las
siguientes condiciones un crecimiento
inusual como un pólipo quiste o tumor
una piedra en la vejiga o cerca de la
misma inflamación o infección crónica
una estenosis o estrechamiento de la
uretra agrandamiento de la glándula
prostática o úlceras en la pared de la
vejiga
antes del procedimiento es posible que
se le introduzca una vía intravenosa
para proporcionarle medicamentos
el médico comenzará aplicando anestesia
local para adormecer el área
una vez que el área esté adormecida el
médico insertará cuidadosamente la punta
de un cistoscopio en la uretra y
lentamente lo hará subir hacia la vejiga
el extremo de cistoscopio contiene una
fuente de luz y lentes que proyectan
imágenes a través de una lente ocular y
en una pantalla de vídeo
al introducir una solución estéril clara
el médico expandirá la vejiga examinará
cuidadosamente las paredes de la vejiga
y la uretra mirando a través de la lente
ocular del si estos copio y observando
las imágenes proyectadas en la pantalla
de vídeo
cuando el médico finalicé éxitos copio
será extraído inmediatamente después del
examen el médico podrá informarle lo que
observo si se tomó una biopsia por lo
general los resultados estarán
disponibles en algunos días
este procedimiento usualmente dura de
entre 2 a 10 minutos
generalmente podrá irse a su casa de
inmediato después del acys tosco pía es
probable que el médico le recete
antibióticos para evitar una infección
también le puede ofrecer medicamentos
para cualquier incomodidad persistente